having bowed to the demands of
large-scale nationwide anti-government
protests French president Emmanuel
macron is facing more trouble on yet
another front a left-wing MPs have
tabled a motion of no confidence in his
government with the vote to take place
later on Thursday
Annina may have given the impression
that it wasn't my concern that I had
other priorities Geneva will see because
of this crisis I want to reconcile with
you
salaries will increase by 100 euros in
2019 at no extra cost to employers
france's so-called yellow vests have
been up protesting on mass for four
consecutive weekends
what started as a demo against a now
scrapped increase in fuel prices evolves
into people airing their grievances
against the government in general but
after even after microns concessions
though some people are still unhappy
they see also like washer Emmanuel
macron speech was addressed to hind
workers only the minimum wage has
nothing to do with us we're not even
talking about working overtime because
when you work 70 hours per week you just
can't understand what that is he forgot
that every other farmer earns less than
365 years per month that our pensions
are lower than Social Security benefits
we pay taxes as all other citizens do
and even if you have no income you still
have to pay taxes the yellow fest
movement has spread beyond the borders
of France with protesters in Canada also
now donning high visibility clothing at
rallies among them is a Karina camo
she says the protesters want to remind
officials they work for the people not
the other way around we're still in the
process of establishing ourselves and
organizing everything here so I think
what's most important is the combined
intention that we have here to create
positive change we're against carbon tax
because history has shown that we can't
possibly tax a nation into prosperity I
think that that only serves to make
economic life even more difficult for
all of us families and
small medium-sized businesses here are
already struggling basically what we
want to do is just be heard by our
government we want to know that our
government has our best interests in
mind we just want to remind our elected
officials that they work for us and we
don't work for them